hello and welcome to this video I made a
pretty stupid misclick they are stopping
the recording right after right after
starting it so welcome again basically
I'm playing Z so master here on niches
and we have a French defense not by
usual opening but I wanted to try
something else I have really have no
clue about this year but maybe I can
just do this I wanted to play this the
Queen takes d5 line I am that is a
little bit disconcerting with a chick on
c7
yeah anyway it's it's it's interesting
to play something different the knight
on a6 is some really big of an opponent
bit of a problem here okay yeah let's
put a bit of pressure on that night
tween f3 maybe he was a little bit
concerned how to develop the queer the
king side by the Queen on d5 putting
some pressure there okay so if I take he
will take with the noise it seems
[Music]
but should be 525 is not go tell
I definitely need to get rid of this
piece it's just so annoying
I don't be five I try to cover a seven
so that I maybe can move the night in
the future once this frog issue is
resolved
it's really a bit of a pain here maybe
I'm too concerned I remind my
development it's not too bad so maybe
things are not so bad but I really
dislike this situation also I probably
should trade to clarify the situation
now I'm ready for ninety seven you know
which was duly prevented so 95
really why does that work
I'm just blonde as a piece
and have a piece of oh my let's not
let's not be too quick okay let's play a
good technical game or try at least so I
can't you cover everything you that's a
good one to trade 993 m I have 93 but
you know it looked a little bit
uncomfortable on this game and I think
this is the line I've seen this line
perform quick f3 maybe the engine gives
Knight c3 here I think there is a game I
don't I'm not totally sure the big guys
yeah cars in car one or something like
that we're after Queen f3 a queen move
Bishop a6 the night was blundered I
remember something there was some some
game okay Queenie a3 was played Bishop
d7 I think this looks fairly normal
Bishop c5 yeah I was just trying to
cover a 7 and of course to prepare
castling and now taking maybe this is
not too bad I was quite concerned but
the position is probably quite playable
yeah Bishop d6 is just him just a big
lemon you should go back and then I was
I wasn't entirely sure if I go night to
c7 now or what I do the engine simply
wants to take and play Bishop e7
and it is that just make quite a good
impression by the way because if it
comes here and 95 the pieces are quite
okay you know I would probably I
considered this I'm sorry Bishop to 3 I
can say that this but it looks a little
bit unharmonious and indeed iam take
take 95 but why Bishop c6 cannot go here
then the pressure is mounting it looks a
little bit of that looks awkward
yeah very awkward Jim so probably after
this I should take on b5 as the engine
suggests this was just giving me a piece
just a piece for for nothing ok guys
thanks for watching